with. Welcome to another Zoom call. We've got a number of questions that came through.
Just again, reminder for everyone. Ask your questions on the member's site. So this
is actually just a clip from the announcements on the home page of your members only site.
Ask your questions on the member's site. You can ask what.
Right now, we don't have a limit if it does get to be excessive.
I'm going to have to pick and choose some of the questions, but I try to get to all of them. I've never missed one yet. So that doesn't mean I won't do the future, but.
And remember, you all have access to the courses. These are the courses that we have up right now.
The beginning of the year, I'll have an autoimmune course up as well.
And we'll have a short mushroom course that you guys already know all about anyhow. So.
Okay, so here's a big question. So I got my genetics report back.
Questions about priorities. I've lost a lot of weight because of squama cell carcinoma on my tonsil and my neck lymph nodes.
I have a hard time swallowing. So I have to chew so much that my appetite declines with an effort.
I've kept myself from losing too much weight by making 2P protein shakes every day, only with nut butters and coconut oil.
Good fats eating avocados more good fats with my eggs. But now I need to follow a low histamine diet. So your histamine genes were you had a lot of defects on the genes, but losing weight.
My trumps of that. So I would continue with eating the nut butter and avocado and forget about that piece of the low histamine diet.
So don't worry about that.
That fact I would probably just don't worry about the histamines at all.
Accepted foods that probably you should be avoiding any how much you want.
In addition, I was supposed to limit animal proteins. But scrambled eggs are one of the things I can manage as well. So keep eating those as well.
A problem with my PSAT1 gene can cause cancers to grow and animal proteins can stimulate that but we're really talking meat.
So don't worry about eggs.
How do I keep from losing weight? How much protein should I have and from where?
I have a magic bullet blender. Should I start making vegetable juices? Will this cause my glucose to rise too quickly?
Because of because time restricted eating has been in the recommendations. So I'm assuming keeping my glucose in some levels, what would be important?
The answer to this is going back to how do I keep losing weight? Most people think that if they want to keep from losing weight, they have to eat more proteins.
I'm not against doing those shakes that you're doing because they can add some caloric intake as well.
But really to keep from losing weight, you need complex carbohydrates, not so much proteins, not that you don't need protein for muscle mass.
But the way you gain muscle mass is by doing some exercise.
As we have several blog posts about exercising with cancer and doing some weights like some just some barbells, 10 pound barbell weights would be bloody adequate and doing some squats and just try to exercise your muscles.
As far as weight loss going back to that, eating some complex carbohydrates is the way to go. I don't want carbohydrates in my glucose to spike.
You'll eat lower glycemic index carbohydrates. Sweet potatoes can be really good. Rice can be really good.
So those are the things that you need to add some complex carbohydrates so that you don't lose weight.
Next question. I wanted to let you know I feel so much better with the new supplements.
Level happy and don't feel that energy ain't going all day and it feels great. One thing, I still dip around 3 p.m. and get very tired.
When it passes as I continue, then it passes as I continue my day. Should I take something at that time?
Well, if you have like a dip in fatigue at a certain time, one thing that I would check is your glucose levels.
It's really fairly inexpensive to go to target or wall bar or your local pharmacy and get a little glucometer bigger brick checker.
So you can check your glucose levels at that time, just to see if you're experiencing some hypoglycemia.
That'd be the case. But if your glucose level dips around that time, I don't know.
Are you eating that to a clock? Are you eating it at noon? And then your blood sugar spikes normally after you eat to then goes back down to normal.
But if your experience is a hypoglycemia because it couldn't be dropping lower than normal at 3 o'clock and that'd be part of the cause of fatigue.
But could it be an adrenal issue? Quite possibly too. A little bit more difficult to die. I know she need a adrenal test might be good to have that glucometer comes in handy for a lot of things just to check your glucose.
Certainly, if it is hypoglycemia, if your glucose is down to 70 or something like that at that time, just make sure you're eating something before that time.
Maybe that will help boost it up. If it's adrenal fatigue, could you take an adaptogen?
So your first go to with any type of adrenal fatigue or hormone imbalance would be an adaptogenic herb. There's numerous adaptogens but our store all are really good.
I think this person has started an adaptogen, so it might be good to take one at that time too.
I do a little bit of experimenting on those things. I was reading a book about cancer therapies that it was suggested that robin accommodation at 50%
is just a liquid iodine. 50% DMSO into tumors could be good. Is this same?
If so, how about enlarged lip nodes? So iodine is really for breast cancer. So I think this person was reading a book about breast cancers.
Maybe wrong, but I think that's what they were reading. So if you had a different type of cancer, I wouldn't necessarily suggest iodine.
DMSO dimethylsoboxide is an anti-inflammatory in itself. And using just straight DMSO over a tumor like a breast cancer can be beneficial.
Just as an anti-inflammatory, but DMSO is an excellent driver, meaning that it absorbs like instantly.
If you put DMSO on your hands, you will taste garlic in your mouth, relatively, very short period of time, I can admit it.
Why garlic? Because the sulfur in this is same sulfur that you find in garlic and onions and things like that.
So that's why you taste that. You taste that sulfur. You have that sulfur taste. There's nothing wrong with it. Some people might have a pleasant, but DMSO in it by itself is a treatment for inflamed joints, some rheumatoid arthritis, any type of degenerative arthritis.
And it could be really beneficial for injuries and the injury, et cetera.
But if you have breast cancer using iodine with DMSO, it drives the iodine into the cancer. Is there any downside to that?
No, not really. You can't get too much iodine. So I would be careful using it like liberally.
You, but I don't see any downside with doing this at all.
I got my tumor markers, blood work back. My CEA was 1.8. That's good. CA 1999 was less than two. So that's good.
CA 2729 plus 32.
That's still within more of a limit. CA 153 was high at 29.8 since the upper limit was 25.
I know I'm supposed to use these for comparison, but do the numbers as they are, tell me anything about my current cancer state.
No, they don't. This is like taking you already know you have cancer. So you could have one or more of your true markers elevated.
Right now you only have one. If we don't have a comparison, then it's, it's just your, it's just your first picture.
So that you would compare, you know, you might want to do this again in two months or something like that and run this test again.
And see where it's at so that you can have some comparison.
Well, the local infosite case was actually low at 37, not sure that means anything.
Internets and could, it could be a zinc deficiency.
Low alkaline phosphatase could be also a low thyroid could be a little parathyroid. It could be.
Right, it would be 12 edemia could be folate edemia or phosphate levels could be a lot of things.
If, you know, if all your other numbers were within normal limit.
I think this would be a probably just leave that alone. If you're noticing some fatigue, maybe taking some B12 in the form of hydroxyl, cabolamine.
Every couple days might be beneficial to see if it's because B12 edemia can lead to fatigue to that's why I'm asking.
So B12 hydroxyl, cabolamine is pretty inexpensive supplement. So it's worth taking it. Usually that's a loss in sublingual loss.
Okay, I also found it curious that my fasting glucose was 88, not too different than normal.
Consider it had been doing pretty much low carb and eat only a seven or eight hour window. I heard that my cancer, it's best to have a lower fasting glucose or is insulin more important effort to ask for that in the lab.
Timestricted eating was a new recommendation for me after the genetics, though I've really been doing that.
So yes, if you're, you already are doing the time.
So no fasting glucose of 88, is that high given you've been working so hard on your diet?
No, I would not say that's high. Your glucose levels in the blood are dependent greatly on your diet.
But there's also an issue with your cell membranes, not able to get the glucose in your blood. So a person that say, let's say they have elevated glucose levels, let's say they don't have cancer.
They go into their own glucose levels, elevated to, let's say one 20. So it's three diabetic state.
So they go on this massive diet and they clean up their diet and they can't seem to bunch the glucose levels very quickly. Why is that?
Well, still carbohydrates that you're eating, unless you're going on a completely ketogenic diet, you will still break down foods into glucose because you need glucose to make energy in your cells.
And so even fatty acids will break down in ways to get your elevated glucose. You have glucose stored in your liver as glycogen.
Your body is trying to make glucose in order to make energy.
If because of a great diabetic state for 15 years, you have damage to your cell membrane receptor sites and your new cells are replicated on same damage cell membrane receptor sites for glucose and insulin, then you can still have an elevated glucose.
So technically, long answer to this question. No, I think you're just fine with that. You just continue doing the right thing. Don't worry about that.
You really don't, you just don't want it to be still 150 or something. If that was the case, then everything I said would probably be going on, probably had high elevated glucose before.
You see diabetic type of diabetic patients that you can't get their glucose to bunch under 180, no matter what you do, no matter what medication they're on.
They're just, you know, it's just have such damage to their cell membranes.
What do you think about the eat right for your blood type diet? I've always wondered if it was legitimate or useful to know that we need anymore layers to worry about it.
I think he has some valid points in that in his book, that book came out a number of years ago, has some valid points. I do think that he is right that some people do better with protein, some people do better with a vegan diet, some people do much better eating a lot of animal proteins.
I do think that's right, but I don't think that it ties to your blood type.
Back when that was really popular, I used to test people non cancer patients for this.
And I found that a lot of what he said was correct, but it didn't tie to the person's blood type.
I do think there's other metabolic factors that are in place. Personally, I could be vegan and I have no issues. If my wife goes vegan, her energy just crashes and we don't have the correct blood types that meet that.
So I think there's some validity to it, but I don't think it ties to the one type.
When we're told to eat more beets, does it matter if they're cooked or raw? No, you could use beets if you want to eat raw beets, you could even pickle beets.
What's the benefit of eating beets or beets have some nutritional benefit? They do have some sugar content, but they're good for your blood, they're good for building your blood.
So, they're beneficial. The subitip oxlates are probably what are told separate. Yes, that's correct. Our golden beets also a good choice. Yes, they're also a big choice too.
Okay, from the chat, I had an MRI and a follow up to a CT scan.
Another question is should I have a different right program? What else should I consider doing the result? There is no lesion to suggest metastasis in the liver. That's good.
Non-specific millimeter.
Milometric lesions with contrast enhancement in the diaphragmatic dome in segment eight of the right loan in the right and in the right loan.
There is not any significant difference in size collection with the dense contents.
We need to enter a part of the right loan deliver and enter a valuable rotation anomaly in the bilateral candies, bilateral renal cortical cysts abuse cardio vaguely.
Is there something I can do to address these findings?
No, you can't. I don't know if there's cyst programs that are on the right. You can search on the right, if there's cyst programs, cysts are very common for a lot of people. Some people are prone to produce a lot of cysts grow their whole body.
And I think there's a program for that cardio vaguely is an enlarged heart.
There's so many causes of that. I have an enlarged heart because I was an athlete in high school. That's the most common cause for that. It's usually not an issue whatsoever to even have to deal with.
It's something you really have to do. You may have some abnormal heartbeats and some arrhythmium due to that, but typically it doesn't cause any problems.
As far as the MRI results of the cancer, there's no changes that need to take place.
Remember, if you do have a metastasis of your cancer, let's say a breast cancer and your metastasis deliver.
Oh my gosh, I just want to deliver. Do I need to change my program? The answer is no, because you do have metastasis from the primary cancer to a secondary site. It's still the same cells of that primary cancer.
So you're still want to run breast cancer in the example I'm giving programming for the metastasis to deliver. So good question.
I have started having my amalgam pillings removed. I'm taking the key look clear and the binder that you recommend. Vodels say to take four day of the key look clear and two a day of the binder is that what you would recommend should they be a divided doses.
Yeah, that would be fine to take there. The key look clear is a bind is a key lady to agent has its name and that will grab things on the blood and the tissues the binder grabs things in the gut and make sure you don't reabsorb the things that your liver's getting rid of.
But you should always try to divide your doses and your supplements. So even if I recommend you take three a day or something it's best if you could split them into morning due to nighttime. Some people are just horrible at doing that.
It just had a timer on your phone or something but it's always take sample always best to take something that's a divided doses because they have a half light.
So I take, you know, for a day of something that I take them in the morning, literally at the end of the day, there might be nothing circulating in my blood.
That's how your body gets through the thing. So you have a half light of different nutrients as well. So you want to break them up and divided doses and let her what you're taking the best you can do.
Even your shakes and or you know a lot of people I have a shake or a smoothie.
It would be best if you could break it into two doses, put half of it in the fridge and drink half of it the afternoon.
I know I don't state that anywhere or I used to tell people to take about three or four hours to drink it.
It's just hard to do that. I don't do that because it's this hard to do that. You just do the best you possibly can.
Is muscle testing done with recommended additional supplements to go with the genetics? No. So those are based upon your genetics.
So when we make a recommendation based upon your genetics, this is just a recommendation based upon your genetics and what you have to take in.
A count is that just because I might have let's let's use the example. See I have horrible histamine genes, just horrible histamine genes.
Does that mean I'm about to determine or to have horrible problems with histamine? No, it does not.
Does it mean that I have a much greater possible chance of having problems with histamine? Yes, it does. Should I take precautions? Yeah, maybe.
But do I have to balance them with dealing with cancer? I'm dealing with a lot of things. I'm you know trying to do so many things.
You do have to balance out your life that way too. So while I'm doing this, I'm calling and looking up my window and I watching this wax grill tried to manage its way down to a bird feeder that's snowing and the top of the bird feeder is metal.
And he's sitting at the bird feeder and now he just popped out poor little guy. He just can't stay on that bird feeder because it's slippery. Sorry, I do.
I'm going to trick there, but yeah, so you have to kind of weigh that out. Let's say I'm not having any issues with histamines. Do I have to be concerned or even take the recommended supplements? No, you don't.
So it would be unethical for us not to tell you. I mean, that's why you're doing the genetics to see to show you what you could have problems with.
I was reading about coffee and abes and how they work. Apparently a part of the sigmoid collid communicates with the liver and helps with detoxification.
So it does indirectly. So part of the sigmoid collid you have really exposure of your cranial nerve 10, your vagus nerve or your vagal nerve endings.
The cranial nerve 10 goes back to the brain and it is the control of your parasympathetic nervous system. Your parasympathetic nervous system controls all your detoxification pathway.
Your parasympathetic nervous system also controls your immune system. So stimulation of the parasympathetic does multiple things.
It helps stimulate detoxification in your liver. It helps stimulate your immune response. It also helps you relax, calm down, helps decrease anxiety.
You live in a sympathetic, driven world. So anything, you know, we're everybody's burning the candlelit both ends, everybody's stressed to the hill. So anything you could do to stimulate parasympathetics, the better.
Did my surgery and part of my sigmoid collid removed does this mean that the coffee and abes won't work as well for me.
I don't know, we don't know how much of the vagal nerve ending part was was removed. I would also suggest you go back to our main website. I think I have another member site to
go to start searching parasympa and you'll come up with this parasympathetic sympathetic exercises. So other you could download a painting of the different silly little exercises that will help stimulate your parasympathetics.
And the silly little exercises that will help calm your sympathetic. So the idea is you're trying to stimulate parasympathetics and we're trying to calm the sympathetic response.
They do seem silly little exercises, but they are rooted in functional neurology and they can be super helpful.
So I'd highly suggest you everybody downloads those looks at them and starts doing some of those things because they can be really helpful.
Coffee enemas are just one thing that can stimulate your parasympathetics. There's a whole bunch of other things.
And there's a bunch of different things that you could do to calm your sympathetic.
And then you can do some of these squirrel game up on the bird feeder.
So a little frustrating.
Any other questions.
All right. Well, you're concerned. I noticed I'm having more pain in my pain. Chris than usual. Is this normal.
Well, if you're having the I do have a video of the website called good paid man paid that you might want to watch.
Because there is a level of good pain when you have cancer. So you're running the right and you feel it.
I would say that's good. If you're like just during the day you're getting paid, that might not be good.
You may want to run another C89 if that was elevated. I can't remember if it was on you, but that was a elevate just to see some things without having to do something like.
You know, well, CT or something like that.
But definitely there can be good. Can be that your your immune system is attacking it.
And you can have more inflammation of the area. So that would be a good cancer paid. It's harder to serve.
Whether it's good or bad. If, you know, so you just have to kind of look at some other factors that are involved too.
What are your supplement recommendations for estrogen positive breast cancer?
I would go to the there are.
I would go to specifically with favera. So I would go to our blog post on a robotase inhibitors, a robot to start typing in a robotase.
And it's a natural aroma taste inhibitors.
I would really look at them.
Calcium de gluten rate. So for a sign.
Products.
The.
Our aroma clear.
Our astral clear, which is a lignin product.
Those are the those are the biggies that you would use from a natural perspective for estrogen, progesterone or her two positive breast cancer is any of those.
But I do list them out on that a robotase inhibitors blog. So I think that will be helpful for you.
Is it elevated heart rate something to worry about? It is.
It's especially in the middle of the night when running by right. Do I need to give myself more space?
Since I cuddle with my little mom, buddy, every night.
Possibly. So it might be up something that you're ready something in your program that's.
Just affecting your. So what would affect your heart rate? So something that is calling for like an increased blood flow that could affect your heart rate.
Something.
That would be my first thought.
Do you do you wake up with it?
And then you find your heart really racing. And are you checking it and see what it's at?
Or is it just something when you get out of bed at night to go to the bathroom? You notice that.
I'd want to really find out some more information that might not have anything to do with the right at all.
It could be usually I wake up and really hot.
Okay, so that is more likely your hormones that it is has anything to do with the right.
If you're going through.
I had to call up your information to see where you're at with them.
Metapause and things like that. If you're going through early.
Metapause. That can certainly cause an issue.
If you're taking.
Anything to decrease estrogen that we just spoke about from a natural perspective in or if you're taking any medical aroma taste inhibitors.
Things that will drop your estrogen level that can that is more most likely to cause somebody asked a question a few weeks ago.
They're not out of any medical aroma taste inhibitors out of the drugs to decrease estrogen.
But they started the astro clear and they said they're getting hot flashes.
And my comment was, well, that's a good thing because that's showing that it's really working.
So we want to think is that you can get hot flashes and elevated heart rate with is when your estrogen levels.
And so that's what we're attempting to do if that is what if you're taking them so I don't not look at your chart right now to see what we have you would.
But if that's the case, then that would be a good thing.
So yes, we have your unclear deal. So yes, so that would actually I would think that would actually be a good thing.
So folate okay to take if you should not take anything methylated.
No, so methyl folate is a methylated product.
Now, again, somebody asked me a while ago that they have really high levels of a need showing a need for methylation.
And typically we tell people that you should not be taking methylated products.
If you have cancer because methylated products can give off a methyl group and that's the whole idea.
And methyl groups can turn off tumor suppressor genes.
So the only caveat to that was if you have really high homocysteine levels, that could lead to this person can have comorbidities right has nothing to do with cancer, the high homocysteine levels, but that can lead to blood vessel damages.
The only thing you'll achieve in heart attack. So then you may have to take some folate.
So methylated products might have to be kind of override the other option.
But if that's not the case, you don't have elevated homocysteine levels.
Now, you don't even know what homocysteine is. You've never seen that on your blood test that I would say that you should get your folate through your food, your green leafy vegetables.
There's some natural folated greens. First, if you're taking that and not be taking any methyl folate here.
Can I break up my time throughout the day with my wife or is it best to run all night? Well, you can break it up during the day if you want to run it during the day.
You can do that certainly.
My idea of running it through the night is you have to sleep at night anyhow. So that's why I program it that way.
We have people that run it during the day as well. So they might work from home and they run it during the day at their desk or whatever.
So some people set up their home where they can do that as well.
Okay, how long should you take the bearer?
So, um, this, what you're taking here.
So, for mayor is a hormone based type of chemotherapy used for estrogen positive patients.
I legally can't comment a drug. So I can't tell you how long you should take it.
I know that I think the standards of care for electrosol is.
I think it's very common and I could be wrong that an oncologist said that I had states and this person is not in the state.
But oncologist said that I had states would put you on for five years, typically.
So that is an aerobatic inhibitor. That's what we're talking about.
So, um, is it a good idea to keep taking it? I can't comment on that legally. I just can't comment on drugs.
That would be practicing medicine.
So, um, you will have to consult with your oncologist about that. Could you do a natural approach?
You certainly can. We have people that do natural approach also, um, but that would have to be a decision that you had to make with your oncologist.
Any other questions?
And I send you my RGCCS results. Yes.
Um, typically don't recommend that you set up a time for me to talk to you about them. That's not my specialty.
Make sure you talk to whoever ordered it for you. But certainly we should have it in your file. So if you have those, I'd like to have it in your file for sure.
Any results you do want to send to us, send it to labs at cutters, clinic or info with cutters, clinic and remember, just because you send us a lab does not mean that I'm going to call you and talk to you about it.
If you want to talk what you want to call and set up an appointment, um, to do so.
And again, I can't give legally, can't give medical advice when we can go over what those labs need.
Certainly you can ask them just like this person did, um, in the chat today or actually in the questions today asked about their different labs.
I think that's beneficial for all to hear those. I think those are really good questions to ask so the people understand.
Um, their labs as best they can so they're not happy to rely just on a doctor explainments to them.
All right, we will end our chat. Oh, what's your thoughts about Dr. Brzynski? Does he treat similar to what you do?
No, he does not treat similar to us at all. Dr. Brzynski has a clinic in Houston.
He's noted treatment is a drug that he developed called anti neoplasty therapy. He does not use it on all patients.
Um, insurance doesn't cover it's for expensive last time I heard somebody checked one of our patients checked it was like $80,000 a month or something like that.
And you have to be on it for six months or some crazy number like that.
I'm not saying that it isn't valuable and it doesn't work. I thought that he would originally started it was mainly just for brain cancer.
I think he's expanded and got an approved for other things as well. He's been attacked by the American Medical Association of the Texas Medical Association for decades.
But he does standard ecology too. So he does chemotherapy and stuff as well. He doesn't do all that much.
The only natural thing he does quote unquote is the anti neoplasty therapy, which is technically a drone.
But it's really based on natural one thing. So he's spent he's kind of listed as a natural alternative doctor, but he really does standard care.
All right, well thank you guys will see you in a couple of days and you have a great day. It is snowing here.
Hopefully you got beautiful weather where you're at.
All right, get your questions in our member site and make sure you utilize anything there that could be a help for you to know that I'll be praying for you.
And I love you all will see you talk to you in a couple of days.
I'll see you in a couple of days.